all right bladesmiths your blades were
tested they've been evaluated the judges
have deliberated and here are the
standings
in fourth place we've got gary earning
one point
in third place gene you earn three
points
and our first place competitor
is chad you got 10 points buddy matt
that leaves you with six everybody's
done fantastic work and now it's time
for our second event
all right gentlemen over here on our
pantry shelves we've got stacks of 15
and 20 and 10.95 steel what does that
mean gentlemen
that's right this is a damascus
challenge and it's gonna be made even
more tough because in our second event
you're not making just one blade you're
making two throwing knives
gentlemen do your best your three hour
starts now
i've never made a throwing knife so
today's gonna be my first and second
throwing knife
i'm taping up my ruler so i can't screw
up my perimeters all i gotta do is stay
between these two blue lines and i'm
golden
[Music]
if you start with good steels makes it a
better possibility of getting good welds
the only kind of throwing weapon i've
ever made before was a tomahawk and
that's not at all the same
i designed kind of a throwing knife got
a good tip on it
but it's also going to have a lot of
meat so that you can really feel it when
you're throwing it
i really want to focus on keeping it
simple just really trying to meet the
parameters
it's tall order but i feel confident in
my skills
so i'm satisfied with the taking of my
wealth so now it's time to dance with
big blue
me and big blue we got a relationship
now
you know we're pretty tight i actually
narrow it down in the center and i'm
going to draw out the handles
at this point everything's going great
couldn't be happier
so it looks like my billet's up to heat
i'm going to set my welds with a hammer
it's a lot more cautious approach to me
to set it by hand but you know i can't
be too careful at this point i can
really be particular on exactly where i
hit the billet
and not been too violent by going over
to big blue and just smashing the heck
out of it
i really need to get the billet nice and
hot so that these pieces will all forge
well together so i don't want to rush
this part of the process if they don't
set i'm not going to be able to to get
two knives out of the steel i get my
steel hot and i'm over to the press
oh no those welds didn't hold it's kind
of like if you're making that big
sandwich take a big bite and everything
comes out the other damn end and it's
all over the floor so now i'm looking at
my billet it's not forge welded and i'm
gonna have to
figure this out right now i can't come
in fourth cause that's gonna put me out
of the competition
this time i get it really hot and allow
the width of that dye to sandwich it
down
i do feel like it's starting to weld to
itself which is the ultimate goal but
it's going to have to go right back in
the heat i'm going to have to repeat
this process a few times before i could
really start drawing this out
my game plan is try to get these two
knives as similar as possible
now i have two identical throwing knives
at 12 inches long i realize that they're
real heavy i want them heavy you have to
throw them real hard but man do they
stick and they make a really loud funk
[Music]
so i finally get my steel drawn out cut
them in half
i want to quench my blades early so
that's going to guarantee me a hard edge
i wouldn't call them knives yet
they're more like bricks
i feel good but i know that it's still
really anyone's game
i make the decision to just quench the
tip thinking that's the only critical
area of the blade i have one of my
knives cooling down so what i need to do
is set up another vise at another
station so i go to the scrap bin i'm
gonna go find two matching pieces of
angle iron
ow
i snagged the inside of my left arm i'm
that guy i'm bleeding on fortune fire
[Music]
i'm just gonna do a little bit of an
edge quench there's no need for the tank
or the spine of the knife to be hard i
mean we're sewing these things around so
you don't want them to break
as i'm starting to finish up and
realizing that they're pretty similar
it's what i was shooting for but things
don't always work out when you only have
three hours
my plan is to heat treat one knife and
then the other
i'm just gonna harden maybe the last
quarter of the night because that's the
part that's going to be digging into the
wood i'm feeling pretty good you know
we're down to the wire so i'm going to
have to keep hustling but i'm going to
work till the last second
[Music]
i've got the edges kind of profiled in
it's time to start working on the handle
but the problem is the buffing belt took
my edge with it
oh boy
i don't have time to fix it so here i am
again uh stuck with some
bad on-the-spot decisions
five four
three
two
one
placement stop what you're doing shut
down your machines drop your tools
i'm frustrated i'm disappointed but i'm
also relieved because i was concerned i
wasn't going to be able to turn anything
in
all right gentlemen welcome to the knife
throwing triple threat
all right gene you're up first you ready
yes sir
[Music]
[Music]
all right so gene right off a lot of
weight to these it's a fairly classic
shape overall for a thrower what i do
appreciate is that the handles
are even in size the handles feel the
same regardless of the knife which isn't
really what i was looking for when we
moved to the harder target this knife
did take a bit of damage and you did
lose just the tip right there just
packed out a little bit but these didn't
start out with a lot of point on them
anyway but uh they threw well
good job thank you sir all right chad
you're up you ready for this yes sir
okay let's do this
[Music]
all right so chad i think you nailed it
these are a great weight a great size
feels super comfortable in my hand they
match really nicely this is something
that's super important in throwing your
tips
they hit into the clay pigeons didn't
lose any tip just a great job all the
way around nicely done thank you gary
you're up you ready for this let's do it
okay
all right so right off uh when i looked
at these i was like nah i don't like
them
i've proven wrong again
these actually throw really good i did
not think this skinny dropped handle
with throw well it actually feels better
like that i was throwing them with the
curve
going up into my hand as opposed to down
they throw really nicely they got a
really sharp point on them when it
penetrates it just buries itself really
nicely the back of the handle there's a
couple of spots on here that i can feel
uh they didn't really drag when it left
my hand but they threw really well so
good job thank you all right matt
you're up next
you're ready to go sure
nice
[Music]
thanks brother
so matt
these things are heavy these have what i
like to call the brick factor
it's like throwing a brick
it doesn't matter if you hit it with
point or not whoever your hits going
down the blades themselves don't quite
match we've got one lean blade and one
wider blade but what i do like is the
handles match beautifully
and they really fit my hand well they do
have a very acute point in profile i
would have loved to have seen a little
bit leaner but i mean it's it's hard to
argue with uh
how easy it was to get accurate with
these as far as being tough
your points
are still there
hold on thank you sir
[Music]
all right blade smith's the second event
and the summer forging games is complete
and the judges need to have a
deliberation i remind you that after
this deliberation
the person with the lowest points will
be eliminated from the games bladesmiths
we need the forged floor thank you
all right blade smith's the second event
in our summer forging games is complete
the judge's deliberation is complete and
they have ranked your work
in first place
chad congratulations that's 10 more
points to you buddy giving you a point
total of 20.
in second place
gary
our come from behind guy you came out of
that first round with just one point and
now you've made up another six points
giving you seven total
our third place finisher is
matt congratulations that's three points
to you adding to your six from the first
event that gives you nine points total
and our fourth place finisher is gene
you came in third on the first event and
here coming in fourth in the second
event gives you one point for a total of
four gene you came out with the least
number of points after two events
unfortunately at this time you've been
eliminated from the summer forging games
my knives perform poorly the other
bladesmiths did a better job and i'm
cool with that it was a good fight man
thank you sir i've learned a lot and i'm
just excited to go back home
put that new knowledge to work become a
better bladesmith and hopefully come
back one day and show these judges what
i'm capable of